bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt pensent à leur première question
c'est l'anniversaire de jolène a songe
aujourd'hui
avez vous des nouvelles de sa santé
physique et psychologique
écoutez moi je suis attentivement ce que
c'était là maurice nous nous apprend on
par réseaux sociaux et médias interposés
et donc on sait bien évidemment depuis
deux ans et demi que la santé d'assange
n'est pas un n'est pas au mieux et c'est
d'ailleurs pour 5 des experts des
nations unies des nations unies pardon
avait d'ailleurs déclaré qu' il fallait
absolument terminer cette incarcération
puisque il subissait un choc
psychologique évident donc on est tous
bien évidemment très inquiet par rapport
à ça alors là ça change
oui concrètement ça veut dire quoi il ya
des mobilisations un peu partout
mobilisation internationale cette
semaine des mobilisations à
l'international et ceux de vos éditeurs
que ok les spectateurs qui veulent s'y
intéresser peuvent retrouver ça sur les
réseaux sociaux et notamment sur twitter
de mémoire il ya plus de 40 pays qui se
mobilisent avec des actions alors pour
nous en france à saint-nazaire à nice ou
moins je serai cet après midi et aussi à
paris de mémoire donc c'est très bien
oui comme fin la société civile se
mobilise à l'international pour leucan
assange qui est le prisonnier d'opinion
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure moi
je tirais prisonniers politiques sur le
prisonnier politique que l'on n'ait nous
en europe
alors j'ai parlé de la france en un pays
où on est on est on est toutes les deux
si je ne trompe pas il n'y a aucun
officiel français car ont répondu
présent à cet appel par exemple les
députés et britanniques alors
effectivement en australie en
grande-bretagne
en italie on a vu cette semaine des
parlementaires italiens s'exprimer mais
aussi en allemagne où plusieurs députés
allemands de partis différents ont écrit
au président wade
en belgique des parlementaires fédéraux
eux écrit au gouvernement britannique
on voit qu'il ya une organisation une
solidarité trans partis de la part de
beaucoup de parlementaires dans
certaines démocraties la france brille
par son silence
la france brille par son absence alors
c'était là maurice un l'accompagnent
julian assange a parlé de courage par
rapport aux états unis elle parle aussi
d' hypocrisie des occidentaux ça veut
dire quoi qu il y a deux poids deux
mesures selon les affaires selon les
dossiers et cas absolument le sait rien
de le dire et je vais faire appel à
votre mémoire
souvenez-vous de du président macron et
de madame angela merkel qui sont
immédiatement précipités médiatiquement
sur la sphère navale nick secoué les
médias il ya quelques mois
et dans la mesure où les comment dire
les les ressortissants sont deux pays
[Musique]
que nos démocraties occidentales
considèrent être soit des dictatures
soit des pays en développement il ya
immédiatement immédiatement une prise de
parole sur justement les droits de
l'homme et le respect des droits de
l'homme
alors pour assange qui est donc enfermé
à londres depuis je crois que c'est la
dixième année 1,6 en six ans et demi à
l'ambassade grecque water plus deux ans
et demi dans cette prison de belmarsh
savait plus de neuf années que ça dure
il n'y a personne et là c'est absolument
choquant parce que justement on voit
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
l'occident a beaucoup de mal à dire
qu'elle a des prisonniers politiques et
des prisonniers d'opinion
alors j'aurai maintenant ou en et quelle
va être la suite on sait que les états
unis ont fait appel 1
la décision britannique de refuser
l'extradition qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et quelle sera donc la suite la suite au
mois d'octobre comme le disait votre
reportage tout à l'heure avec les
prochains à les prochaines les
prochaines audiences en justice on était
peut-être aussi avait une mobilisation
de la france et de tout l'occident voire
de populations partout dans le monde les
choses pourraient bouger
il peut aussi y avoir avec ce 50e
anniversaire donc derrière les barreaux
dans les conditions donc bien de
discuter y avoir d'autres types de
révélations ou qu'il en sorte que les
états unis vont être obligés aussi de
faire marche arrière dans l'eure dans
leur demande à suivre à suivre en tout
cas merci avons stéphanie gibeau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes auteur de la traque des
lanceurs d'alert un ouvrage préfacé par
julian assange mercier merci